le petit ricardo est né en plein
confinement son univers social limité à
quatre personnes
la troisième née en janvier trois jours
après le couvre-feu donc ça a été tout
un ajustement même la grossesse était
différente on n'était plus seule à la
plus heureuse et volé
déjà parents de deux enfants de 6 et 3
ans julie lava tchèque la rondo airdrie
kalil observe des particularités chez
leur bébé de 8 mois au même âge son
grand frère sa grande soeur étaient très
attachés à leurs grands parents avaient
hâte de les voir s'amuser avec avec eux
mais louis le laisser tout seul avec les
grands parents on dirait que c'est une
épreuve pour lui il pleure il fait des
crises et ça ça brise le coeur de ses
grands parents ça nous brise le coeur
leurs observations concordent avec
celles de plusieurs éducatrices en
garderie départ en plus anxieux plus
inquiètes des bébés qui était très
accroché à leurs parents parce qu'il y
avait été en bulles juste avec maman
avec papa peu de contacts avec
l'extérieur dont des enfants plus
craintifs les discussions que j'ai eues
avec certaines éducatrice et rectrice et
on nous parlait de bébés broch qui
demandent plus les bruits qui demandent
plus des prix qui demandent plus d'être
rassuré
on m'a raconté qu'il ya des enfants que
ça leur prix de novembre à mars l'eau à
s'adapter
il semble plus craintifs et plus
sensibles aux bruits pas étonnant que
les chercheurs en petite enfance
s'intéresse au poupon qui sont nés
pendant le confinement c'est une période
qui est vraiment importante au niveau du
développement social une période où
l'enfant apprend à regarder les gens à
décoder les émotions à reconnaître les
intentions de quelqu'un par leurs yeux
par leur bouche par exemple pour appuyer
ses premiers échanges qui passe surtout
par l'expression du visage les
éducatrices masqué par le
continuellement à l'enfant
l'éducatrice votre toujours nommés ce
qu'elle fait donc pour les enfants c'est
rassurant on a quand même toujours
essayé de sortir la pandémie nombre oui
on avait des masques on avait du furet
elle en avait des sarraut mais laquelle
ted ne travaillons pas été compromise
des babys différentes peut-être mais qui
auront développé autre chose le fait que
les enfants ont été confinés avec leurs
parents ils pas nécessairement quelque
chose de négatif dans le sens que
l'enfant ça lui a permis de développer
un attachement un attachement profond
l'ex aux parents un attachement
significatif et ça c'est vraiment
précieux dans l'avis d'impôt ça lui
donne confiance en lui ça lui permet
d'explorer tv
avec la vaccination et le déconfinement
les choses se passent mieux et en
processus d'intégration depuis la new
puis ça rien à voir avec l'année passée
c'est des enfants qui sont sortis ce tt
qui ont été dans les pas des enfants
aussi qu'ils ont revue les grands
parents les familles
[Musique]
les parents de ricardo ont compris qu'il
faudra faire les choses différemment
initialement notre idée c'était en
janvier dès qu'on recommence à
travailler lui aussi commence la
garderie mais on la place on va
probablement commencer en novembre même
de manière très très bas à temps partiel
il faudra y aller de manière très
progressive je pense tout en espérant de
la stabilité pour leur bébé puisque les
garderies sont aux prises avec une
pénurie de personnel ici à nourrice
despatie radio-canada mujer
[Musique]